(blast off and sonic boom)
(piano music)
- [Evan] My founding story.
If you can shape your business
life or your working life,
you can just look at it
at as another extension,
you just fulfill all your
values as a human being
in the workplace.
If you're an activist,
you bring the activism
of your life into your business,
or if you love creative
art, you can bring that in.
Anita Roddick, founder of The Body Shop
and pioneer of ethical consumerism.
I never wanted to tell my story.
When I started my website I
wanted to build a great resource
to help entrepreneurs succeed.
I started with stories
of famous entrepreneurs
like Bill Gates, Oprah
Winfrey, and Walt Disney,
because their stories inspired me.
When I was down, when I doubted myself,
when I felt like I
wasn't going to make it,
I looked to their stories
and they motivated me to keep going.
Bill Gates' story saved my business
and made me stick with
being an entrepreneur.
I wanted to share that
knowledge with others
so they could also be motivated
to continue to pursue their dreams.
I created an awesome website,
but people kept writing in saying,
love the site, but who is Evan Carmichael?
I'm nobody compared to the
entrepreneurs I'm profiling
I thought, but people were
asking so I started to share,
and my business took off.
Suddenly I was attracting more clients,
more website traffic, more
social media followers.
I was selling more products,
getting more newsletter signups,
receiving more media
requests for interviews.
I was having more fun too.
The product I had was already great,
but when I told my story,
it added more context,
it made it feel more valuable,
it connected with people.
When I talk about how I was
making 300 dollars a month
in my first business, and Bill
Gate's story saved my company
and helped me build an
international business
and get acquired just a
couple of years later,
that adds context.
People really want to
hear what I have to say.
I realized that telling my story
wasn't about pumping myself up.
It humanized my business and
made it easier for people
to take whatever next step
I was asking them to take.
It's time for you to write your story.
(upbeat music)
(blast off and sonic boom)